vous connaissez tim ferriss c'est un peu
l'expert en productivité de la silicon
valley son obsession c'est de tester
plein de méthode et de techniques de
trouver les plus efficaces et de s'en
servir pour obtenir des résultats
exceptionnels plus vite et plus
facilement
or il a dit une chose très importante
complexity fail que je traduis par la
complexité mène à l'échec
c'est vrai quoi que vous fassiez c'est
encore plus vrai si vous faites quelque
chose de difficile comme une des certes
à sion
[Musique]
dans cette vidéo je vais commenter une
dissertation de culture générale qui a
été notée 15 sur 20 aux concours
d'entrée de le m
l'école nationale de la magistrature en
2019 si vous voulez avoir de bonnes
bases de méthodologie pour comprendre
mon commentaire de cette copie je vous
conseille de vous inscrire à mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation le lien de sa fiche est
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans la
description c'est un cours par email
donc vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo en
entier
et puis vous découvrirez ma méthodologie
après ou un autre jour vous pouvez
également télécharger la copie le lien
est dans la description
j'en profite pour remercier arthur dont
c'est la copie il m'a autorisé non
seulement à l'utiliser mais aussi à la
commenter dans le détail en vidéo donc
si tu regarde cette vidéo arthur merci
c'est vraiment sympa alors arthur a
présenté le concours de le nm l'école
nationale de la magistrature
comme je l'aï déjà dit la particularité
de ce concours c'est que c'est un
concours de la fonction publique dans ce
concours l'épreuve de dissertation de
culture générale s'appelle plus
précisément connaissance et
compréhension du monde contemporain
depuis 2009 les sujets sont plus
orientés vers les questions
contemporaines pour améliorer l'égalité
des chances mais les sujets sont
toujours inscrire dans une histoire
longue donc c'est toujours de la culture
générale c'était preuve les énoncés
précise que c'est une composition
portant sur une question posée
aujourd'hui à la société française dans
ses dimensions judiciaire juridique
social politique et historique
économique philosophique et culturel
ouh là ça fait peur en plus c'est une
épreuve de 5 heures et candidats ont
intérêt à être préparé ce concours je
connais bien parce que j'ai moi-même
préparer des concours de la fonction
publique pendant deux ans et puis
surtout chaque année et je prépare à ce
concours des élèves inscrits à ma
formation à la méthodologie de la
dissertation
donc je connais bien les attendus de
l'épreuve l'état d'esprit ce qu'il faut
faire et ce qu'il faut éviter le sujet
de 2019 c'était la démocratie alors il
peut paraître difficile parce que ce
n'est pas une question est que ces
vastes mais en même temps c'est un thème
vu et revu par les candidats c'est même
un chapitre dont beaucoup de manuels
donc c'était en réalité un sujet facile
mais ce n'est jamais facile en réalité
parce que les candidats sont évalués les
uns par rapport aux autres
en fait ce sont simplement les enjeux
qui change sur un sujet comme celui ci
par exemple tous les candidats ont des
choses à dire
donc ce ne sont pas les connaissances
qui permettront de décrocher une bonne
note
ce sera l'argumentation et c'est là que
je voulais l'emmener en vous parlant de
tim ferriss au tout début de la vidéo
bien argumenté c'est difficile
donc vous devez éviter la complexité on
va voir comment arthur ci est prévue
cette vidéo est longue donc n'hésitez
pas à la regarder parti par parti pour
accéder à la partie qui vous intéressent
servez vous du minutage dans la
description
n'hésitez pas non plus à m'écrire dans
les commentaires allez c'est parti
prenez de quoi noter mettez votre
téléphone en mode avion et
concentrez-vous je vais procéder comme
un correcteur je commence par me faire
une première impression globale de la
copie
[Musique]
alors voici la copie d'arthur je vais la
regarder rapidement pour me faire une
première impression générale
il a noté le sujet de dissertation c'est
toujours utile
il met bien en évidence les références
dans les soulignant la calligraphie
n'est pas superbe mais ça semble lisible
pour l'instant je vois qu'ils marquent
bien les alinéas ce qui permet de bien
distinguer les paragraphes
je ne sais pas si c'est moi qui lui ai
donné l'idée comme j'insiste souvent sur
ce point mais ce qu'il a fait c'est très
bien pour le lecteur
alors l'introduction est longue voire
très longue quasiment deux pages et demi
c'est souvent la marque des très bonnes
copies mais là je vois quand même des
paragraphes indigeste celui ci par
exemple prend les trois quarts de la
page
j'arrive à l' annonce de plan hockey le
plan est apparent c'est la convention
pour la dissertation de culture générale
de le nm arthur a choisi un plan type
ena en quatre parties grand un abbé
grand 2 ab il annonce laisse ou parti a
et b là je vois l'introduction partielle
c'est bien parce que je me dis déjà
qu'il tient le lecteur par la main et
donc que ma lecture sera plus facile je
descends dans le grand 1 à les
paragraphes sont toujours bien marquées
par des alinéas et arthur saute même une
ligne n'est pas obligatoire mais c'est
encore plus clair
les références sont toujours souligné
petite conclusion partielle avant le
grand 1 b c'est toujours aussi rigoureux
dont la présentation là le premier
paragraphe est un peu long quand même je
crois que je vais souffrir
conclusion partielle avant le grand 2 et
puis même présentation que pour le grand
teint c'est toujours le même format rien
à signaler
j'arrive à la conclusion elle a l'air de
faire le job
le paragraphe est assez long la copie
fait douze pages c'est plutôt long mais
l'épreuve dure quand même 5 heures et
les bonnes copies sont plus longue que
la moyenne
il faudra voir si la qualité est au
rendez vous bon voilà pour ma première
impression
alors qu'est ce que j'en pense j'en
pense que la copie d'arthur semble très
sérieuse visuellement elle est
structurée très clairement et bien aéré
grâce aux alinéas et aux sauts de ligne
je ne perdrai jamais le plan apparent il
va aussi me faciliter la tâche
je ne vois que deux défauts la
calligraphie n'est pas toujours top je
vais peut-être avoir du mal à lire à
certains endroits et le second défaut
c'est que certains paragraphes
paraissent vraiment ça ça me fait peur
parce que c'est le mal de crâne assuré
bon c'est vrai que de toute façon les
correcteurs ne lisent le développement
qu'en diagonale mais moi je vais lire la
copier en entier c'est vrai que c'est
une dissertation sur un sujet
intéressant
bon en conclusion la copie d'arthur
produit une bonne voire une très bonne
première impression à tort correcteurs
je me dis que c'est un travail très
sérieux
je suis ont déjà sous l'emprise d'un
biais de confirmation positif je situe
déjà la copie dans une fourchette de
notes hautes
je sais que sauf accident je lui
mettrais au minimum 12 13 ou 14 voire
plus bien sûr si la qualité le justifie
d'ailleurs le rapport du jury de
l'épreuve de cette même année a souligné
l'importance de la présentation on ne
saurait trop rappeler aux candidats
l'importance du soin apporté à la
présentation formelle des copies on ne
vous demande pas de faire du design mais
le soin sera toujours récompensés bon
voilà pour ma première impression ce que
vous devez retenir c'est que comme
arthur vous pourrait séduire le
correcteur et le présicent poser à
une bonne note en présentant et en
structurant très clairement votre
dissertation allez maintenant temps
d'entrer dans le dur
ce que font souvent les correcteurs
c'est qu'il commence par lire
l'introduction et la conclusion en
tandem avant de regarder le
développement de la dissertation en
diagonale donc je vais faire comme eux
je vais d'abord commenter dans le détail
l'introduction puis la conclusion de la
copie d'arthur allez c'est parti
[Musique]
ah ça fait plaisir d'avoir à faire
quelque chose de clair ce premier
paragraphe je sais qu'il est consacrée à
la croche de la dissertation je n'ai pas
besoin de me prendre la tête
il comporte trois phrases plutôt longue
ce qui est satisfaisant dans la première
phrase arthur introduit une référence un
discours politiques tenus lors de la
révolution française
dans son discours du 7 septembre 1789
l'abbé sieyès laissé entendre que parler
de démocratie représentative est un
oxymore
alors si vous ne savez pas c'est yes est
un célèbre révolutionnaire français il
est notamment connu pour deux essais son
essai sur les privilèges et qu'est ce
que le tiers état qu il devenu un texte
fondateur de la révolution française
le discours du 7 septembre 89 que site
arthur est passé à la postérité comme
une défense du gouvernement
représentatif
ce que disent et yeahs c'est que les
citoyens ne doivent pas faire les lois
eux mêmes mais déléguer cette tâche à
des représentants éclairé autre petite
précision un oxymore c'est une figure de
style qui consiste à allier deux termes
normalement incompatibles l'exemple
qu'on donne tout le temps c'est une
obscure clarté alors la référence est
pertinente puisqu'elle porte sur le
concept de démocratie et sur la forme la
phrase est très claire on saisit son le
sens instantanément arthur explique dans
la deuxième phrase de ce paragraphe
pourquoi seyes considèrent que la
démocratie représentative est un oxymore
c'est à dire pourquoi les idées de
démocratie et de représentativité sont
incompatibles
son explication n'est pas super clair à
son sens
seul le gouvernement peut être
représentatifs n'est pas la démocratie
puisque par définition elle renvoie à
l'exercice du pouvoir dans une société
donnée par le peuple souverain
quel est le problème sur le fond
le problème c'est que la phrase ne se
concentre pas sur l'idée essentielle
quelle est l'idée essentielle qui
justifie l'affirmation de seyes est bien
c'est que dans la démocratie par
définition le peuple souverain exerce
lui même c'est à dire de manière directe
le pouvoir donc arthur aurait pu
expliquer cette idée plus simplement moi
j'ai créerait à son sens
seul le gouvernement peut être
représentatif mais pas la démocratie
puisqu'elle signifie par définition que
le peuple souverain exerce lui même
c'est à dire de manière directe le
pouvoir après la phrase de la copie est
plutôt efficace
l'idée est connecté à la précédente par
un lien logique de précision a son sens
la phrase est bien structuré les
virgules sont au bon endroit
je note simplement que la locution dans
une société donnée est inutile souvenez
vous que c'est important de concentrer
chaque phrase sur l'idée essentielle que
vous souhaitez communiquer alors
troisième phrase de la croche deux cent
trente années plus tard le débat sur la
forme que la démocratie doit prendre est
toujours d'actualité direct
représentative mixte la question est à
nouveau posée là ce que fait arthur
c'est de justifier l'intérêt du sujet il
dit aux correcteurs c'est une bonne idée
ce sujet parce que c'est en effet un
problème intéressant et nous avons donc
intérêt à y réfléchir c'est exactement
ce qu'il faut faire en termes de métaux
dans un premier temps vous capter
l'attention du correcteur avec une
accroche pertinente puis vous justifier
l'intérêt du sujet arthur le fait
d'autant plus intelligemment qu il
souligne que c'est une question
d'actualité qui elle est à nouveau posée
pourquoi cette intelligente parce que
c'est précisément l'enjeu de la
dissertation de culture générale du
concours d'entrée de le nm qui
s'intitule en réalité connaissance et
compréhension du monde contemporain
l'énoncé lui même indique que la
dissertation porte sur une question
posée aujourd'hui à la société française
donc en soulignant dès la fin de la
croche que la question est toujours
d'actualité qu'elle est à nouveau posée
arthur montre qui connaît bien les
règles du jeu et qu'il s'apprête à faire
très précisément ce qu'on lui demande
là ils marquent vraiment des points il
renforce le biais de confirmation
positif créé par la première impression
produite par la copie en tant que
correcteurs je me dis que c'est un
candidat sérieux bien préparé je reviens
à la phrase elle même
deux cent trente années plus tard le
débat sur la forme que la démocratie
doit prendre est toujours d'actualité
direct représentative mixte la question
est à nouveau posée 1789 plus de 130
égale 1789 +200 +30 égale 1989 +30 égale
c'est un détail mais cette précision de
calcul fait bonne impression bon que dit
arthur dans cette phrase il dit que la
question montre et essayer dans son
discours s'est accroché la dissertation
cette question n'est toujours pas résolu
aujourd'hui sur la forme maintenant il
n'y a rien à signaler
la phrase est liée à la précédente par
un connecteur logique date d'audition et
elle est claire plus que la précédente
d'ailleurs
seul petit bémol il fallait plutôt
d'énumérer les formes de la démocratie
directe représentative mixte entre
parenthèses après le verbe prendre
et puis les 3 petits points ça fait un
peu journalistique mais bon ce sont des
détails
et puis ça crée tout de même un peu de
dynamisme
bon voilà pour le paragraphe d'across à
part peut-être la deuxième phrase qui ne
cible pas assez l'idée qu'elle veut
communiquer à part ce petit défaut le
paragraphe et efficace je passe au
suivant
classiquement le mot démocratie est
d'origine grecque le demos signifiant le
peuple le kratos renvoyant au pouvoir la
arthur défini le concept de démocratie
en partant de son étymologie en grec
ancien le pouvoir kratos appartient au
peuple demos il connecte les deux
racines grecques dans la troisième
phrase du paragraphe la démocratie
serait donc l'exercice du pouvoir par le
peuple
c'est bien mais il aurait pu communiquer
l'idée plus efficacement mois j'écrirai
simplement à consulter son étymologie
grecque la démocratie signifie
l'exercice du pouvoir kratos par le
peuple demos les trois phrases d'arthur
sont plutôt efficaces notamment parce
qu'elles sont courtes mais je relève
plusieurs faiblesses
l'adverbe classiquement et inutile
arthur a déjà utilisé le verbe renvoyer
dont le sens et je trouve trop vague
arthur a déjà utilisé ce verbe il ya
quelques phrases autre faiblesse la
deuxième phrase ne comporte pas de
verbes conjugués et enfin il faut
utiliser des guillemets français
apparemment c'est tout pour la
définition des termes parce qu arthur
enchaîne avec un peu d'histoire dans les
deux phrases suivantes
l'idée de démocratie est apparu à
athènes entre le cinquième et le ivème
siècle avant jésus-christ elle ne date
donc pas de 1789
en revanche c'est à partir de cette
année là qu'elle sera admise en france
dans les trois phrases suivantes
il compare la démocratie athénienne et
l'idée de la démocratie qui à nrg lors
de la révolution française
il dit que c'est peut être le facteur de
la taille de la société qui explique la
différence entre ces deux conceptions il
y avait seulement quarante mille
citoyens à athènes tandis qu'il y en
avait environ 28 millions en france à
l'époque de seyes dans les trois phrases
qui suivent celles ci arthur passe sur
le plan des idées où il oppose seyes
l'auteur de son accroche à rousseau
enfin dans la dernière phrase de ce
paragraphe il justifie à nouveau le
sujet c'est aussi celui qui oppose
aujourd'hui une partie de la population
française qui ne se sent plus représenté
bon voila j'ai dévoilé la structure du
paragraphe arthur définit la démocratie
à partir de l'étymologie
il fait un rappel historique il évoque
le facteur démographique pour expliquer
la différence entre les conceptions
athénienne et française il oppose say
yes et rousseau et enfin il re justifie
le sujet de la dissertation
vous voyez le problème c'est beaucoup
trop compliqué il fait cinq choses
différentes dans un même paragraphe
là il a dérapé en termes de métaux dont
il a voulu faire compliqué parce qu'il
connaît bien son cours sur la démocratie
mais il suffisait de faire une seule
chose et éclairer le sens du concept
moi j'aurais d'abord évoqué l'étymologie
comme lui puis dans un second temps
j'aurais opposé l'idée originelle de la
démocratie aux nombreuses et diverses
déclinaisons pratiques qui ont émergé
dans l'histoire des sociétés non
seulement il a existé et il existe des
démocraties dans lesquelles le peuple
n'exerce pas directement le pouvoir mais
il y a aussi des régimes qui n'ont de
démocratique que le nom par exemple la
corée du nord s'appelle officiellement
la république populaire et démocratique
de corée
voici à quoi ressemblerait mon
paragraphe de définition des termes à
consulter son étymologie grecque la
démocratie signifie l'exercice du
pouvoir kratos par le peuple demos ce
concept a cependant inspiré diverses
déclinaisons concrètes
si certaines comme la démocratie
athénienne semble fidèle à l'idée
originelle d'autres comme la cinquième
république française n'apparaissent pas
comme des démocraties chimiquement pur
je me serais contenté de ces trois
phrases
le problème dans la dissertation arthur
c'est qu'ils perdent de vue l'enjeu du
paragraphe définir les termes du sujet
il s'agit juste d' éclairer en quelques
phrases le sens du concept de démocratie
bien sûr il ya des choses intéressantes
dans ce qu'il a écrit
mais tout ça à sa place dans le
développement ou les connaissances
serviront à donner de la force aux
arguments en dissertation vous devez
dire des choses intéressantes au bon
endroit là arthur donne l'impression de
réciter son cours dès le deuxième
paragraphe de l'introduction
j'ajoute que comme il veut trop en faire
la qualité du propos décroît au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance dans le paragraphe
la définition du concept de démocratie
par l'étymologie est bonne le rappel
historique est juste la considération
sur le facteur démographique est
pertinente mais ça devient moins bon
lorsqu'il passe sur le plan des idées
première remarque à quoi bon si tu es
rousseau en une seule phrase juste après
une considérations pratiques sur le plan
de la nature des connaissances mobiliser
ça fait histoire technique philosophie
politique logique c'est difficile à
suivre pour le lecteur j'ajoute que
l'idée de la démocratie représentative
n'a pas émergé dans du contrat social
rousseau il dit simplement qu'on peut
admettre ce système dans de grands
ensembles comme la france si on l'en
cadre strictement en réalité c'est
difficile de dater la naissance d'une
idée mais celle de la démocratie
représentative lé semble remonter aux
débats qui ont accompagné les
révolutions anglaise au xviie siècle
en fait antérieure au bouquin de
rousseau donc avec cette seule phrase
arthur compliquer la lecture est dit un
truc faut en lisant la phrase suivante
on voit qu'il ne sait plus très bien ce
qu'il fait puisque il répète
l'idée selon laquelle la démocratie
représentative serait oxymorique pas
besoin de le dire sans fois on a compris
ensuite il continue de dire des choses
inutiles
à quoi bon préciser ici que le débat
démocratie directe versus démocratie
représentative a opposé rousseau
essayait au xviiie siècle
est-ce que ça fait avancer la résolution
du problème intellectuel
bien sûr que non cette information a
éventuellement sa place dans le
développement et encore ça ne sert pas
montré grand chose c'est plutôt une
phrase qu'on trouverait dans un manuel
d'histoire des idées politiques
et puis sur le fond je ne sais pas si on
peut vraiment parler d'un débat entre
rousseau et c est ce parce que c'est yes
s'est appuyé sur la pensée de rousseau
et parce que rousseau a admis qu'on
mette en place une démocratie
représentative
si on l'en cadre strictement bref arthur
essaie d'en faire trop et du coup ça
devient trop compliqué
d'ailleurs la dernière phrase est
complètement ratée
c'est aussi celui qui oppose aujourd'hui
une partie de la population française
qui ne se sent plus représenté premier
problème une opposition oppose deux
opposants à qui ou à quoi est elle donc
opposé cette partie de la population
française
second problème cette partie de la
population française ne dis pas que la
démocratie est forcément direct elle
n'est pas contre l'idée de
représentation ce qui ne va pas c'est
qu'elle ne se sent plus représenté elle
ne veut pas faire les lois elle veut
qu'on la représente correctement
la arthur confond donc deux idées le
caractère antidémocratique de la
représentation et l'effectivité de la
représentation
bref la fin de ce paragraphe est
vraiment raté arthur ne s'est pas
concentré sur l'enjeu de la définition
des termes du sujet il a voulu faire
plein de choses en même temps et il a
essayé de manipuler des idées compliqué
or il fallait et il suffisait de définir
le concept de démocratie
retenez la chose suivante pour bien
faire
vous devez faire une seule chose par
paragraphe et vous devez la faire
simplement
rappelez-vous la phrase de tim ferriss
complexe city files
allez c'est bon pour ce paragraphe je
passe au suivant
oula c'est paragraphe est super long le
paragraphe précédent servait à définir
les termes du sujet donc celui ci sert
probablement à problématiser le sujet
c'est-à-dire à découvrir le problème
intellectuel à résoudre dans la
dissertation
mais bon arthur a dérapé dans le par
ailleurs précédente donc celui ci ne
sera peut-être pas très rigoureux non
plus à l'aise je commence à le lire
jusqu alors légitime parce que stable la
démocratie semble aujourd'hui remise en
cause
ça c'est le point de départ de la
réflexion d'arthur il semble
qu'aujourd'hui la légitimité de la
démocratie ne soit plus indiscutable sur
le plan de la méthode aux c'est
exactement ce qu'il faut faire il faut
commencer le paragraphe de
problématisation par le point de départ
de votre réflexion
c'est à dire l'idée simple et évidente
contenus dans l'énoncé qui stimule la
réflexion sur le fond l'idée paraît
juste la démocratie française notamment
semble en crise
au niveau de la forme c'est simple et
claire après je n'aurais pas parler de
légitimité ou de stabilité je me serais
contenté d'écrire la démocratie semble
aujourd'hui remise en cause
ensuite je ne comprends pas ce qu'arthur
essaie de faire dans les deux phrases
suivantes il vient d'exposer le point de
départ de sa réflexion
et là il m'explique que la démocratie
française est à la fois représentative
et direct puis dans la 4e phrase du
paragraphe il dit que c'est la
représentation qui pose problème
aujourd'hui est la cinquième phrase
ajoute que la démocratie française
moderne
ce sont aussi les droits et libertés
fondamentaux je m'arrête là parce que ça
part dans tous les sens je récapitule ce
que fait arthur en cinq phrases il
expose le point de départ de sa
réflexion il précise que la démocratie
française est à la fois représentative
et direct grâce à la limite du
référendum il dit que c'est la
représentation qui pose problème
aujourd'hui et enfin il ajoute que la
démocratie française moderne
ce sont aussi les droits et libertés
fondamentaux bon vous voyez le problème
c'est super prise de tête comme dans le
paragraphe précédent arthur se
dispersent et perd de vue l'enjeu du
paragraphe
c'était pourtant simple il a bien posé
le point de départ de sa réflexion
donc il suffisait de les expliquer dans
les phrases suivantes la démocratie
semble aujourd'hui remise en cause je
suis d'accord mais il faut justifier un
peu cette affirmation et c'est à ça que
doit servir le début de ce paragraphe
pour me convaincre que la démocratie
semble aujourd'hui remise en cause
arthur aurait pu évoquer différentes
choses les taux d'abstention aux
élections
la baisse du nombre de militants dans
les partis politiques la défiance des
français envers le personnel politique
révélé dans les sondages le mouvement
des jaunes etc
mais au lieu de ça ils s'emmêlent les
pinceaux et ça l'amène à commettre des
erreurs d'expression
relisez la cinquième phrase de ce
paragraphe alors même qu'au delà de la
faculté donnée au peuple de choisir ses
représentants
ceux ci sont également titulaires de
droits et libertés fondamentaux aussi
bien consacré par des textes que protégé
par des juridictions
vous voyez le problème ceci c'est qui
les représentants le peuple mais le
peuple c'est un nom commun singulier
arthur voulait dire que les citoyens
français sont également titulaires de
droits et libertés fondamentaux comme
dans le paragraphe précédent
la complexité du fonds l'a entraîné à
commettre des erreurs de forme je
continue dans les quatre phrases
suivantes
arthur revient au problème de la
représentation il répète que la
population ne se sent pas représenté
et il explique que ce sentiment entraîne
la remise en cause du système de la
représentation lui même et pas seulement
de la personne des représentants pour le
dire plus simplement les français ne se
sentent plus représentés
donc ils vont jusqu'à penser que le
système est pourri il ne pense pas
seulement que leurs représentants sont
pourris ils pensent que le système
politique n'est pas bon avec ses quatre
phrases arthur précise le point de
départ de sa réflexion
ils précisent la nature de la remise en
cause qui affecte la démocratie
française en termes de méthode hausse
est bon parce que si l'explication du
point de départ de la réflexion sur le
fond ça paraît pertinent mais il faudra
illustrer ses idées pour convaincre le
lecteur sur la forme c'est plutôt
efficace
je comprends le propos facilement donc
c'est clair j'aime bien la deuxième
phrase de ce passage comme elle est plus
courte elle dynamise la lecture et puis
le conditionnel moder l'affirmation
c'est un choix intelligent parce que le
sujet est quand même controversé bon
c'est quatre phrases ne sont pas si mal
moi je les aurai écrite directement
après la présentation du point de départ
de la réflexion
la première phrase du paragraphe c'est à
dire que j'aurais procédé en trois temps
un présentation du point départ de la
réflexion de précision du point de
départ de la réflexion
les quatre phrases que je viens
d'analysé et enfin trois illustrations
pour convaincre le lecteur
justement l'illustration c'est ce que
fait arthur dans les deux phrases
suivantes
il évoque le mouvement des gilets jaunes
qui avaient commencé six mois avant
l'épreuve
et il précise intelligemment que le
problème est plus complexe que ce que
croient les jets les jaunes ah oui c'est
une dissertation pour devenir haut
fonctionnaire quand même la première
phrase est clair même s'il n'était pas
nécessaire de donner la date précise de
la naissance de la vème république
la seconde phrase est moins clair mais
il ne doit pas couvrir à cause des
formes radicales de contestation qui
peuvent surgir la réalité d'une
complexité bien plus profonde que celle
des débordements et qui renvoie à la
question du contrat social lui même
non en fait elle est trop compliqué
arthur répète le mot contestation et
utilise une fois de plus le verbe
renvoyer verbe que je trouve trop vagues
comme je les ai déjà dit moi je réécris
cependant la radicalité de ce mouvement
ne doit pas dissimuler la profonde de
complexité du problème qui est lié à la
question même du contrat social bon
voila tout pour ce long paragraphe pour
le coup il aurait dû être plus court les
phrases deux à cinq ne servent à rien la
précision du point de départ de la
réflexion aurait pu être plus rapide et
je trouve que l'illustration de ce point
de départ est insuffisante
encore une fois la bonne démarche ça
aurait été un de poser le point de
départ comme il l'a fait d'eux de
préciser en deux trois phrases et 3
d'illustrer avec des exemples de donner
des preuves
allez je passe au paragraphe suivant la
arthur fait en deux phrases ce que je
recommande de faire en une seule
question présentait le problème
intellectuel à résoudre dans la
dissertation dans la méthodologie de la
dissertation ça s'appelle la
problématique
joli il faut alors s'interroger sur les
raisons pour lesquelles la démocratie
est aujourd'hui l'objet de controverses
alors qu'il s'agit du modèle de société
choisie il ya plus de deux siècles mais
se pencher sur ces raisons implique
inéluctablement de s'interroger sur la
capacité des français qu'ils soient
représentés ou représentants à repenser
ensemble ce que peut et doit être la
démocratie et donc leur capacité à faire
société
bon moi j'impose à mes élèves d'exprimer
le problème intellectuel de la
dissertation sous la forme d'une unique
question mais c'est possible de le faire
avec une ou deux phrases déclaratives si
c'est très clair vous le trouvez clair
ce paragraphe
bien sûr que non il n'est pas clair
c'est quoi le problème intellectuel à
résoudre et bien en fait il y a deux
problèmes dans le paragraphe là les
raisons des controverses actuelles sur
la démocratie la capacité des français à
repenser la démocratie sur le fond ces
problèmes sont trop vagues
arthur a fourni des précisions dans les
paragraphes précédents donc il faut
qu'ils s'en servent
il l'a dit lui même le problème porte
précisément sur la représentation
et puis il y a des choses inutiles dans
ces deux phrases il n'est pas nécessaire
de répéter que la démocratie est le
modèle de société choisie il ya plus de
deux siècles
il est inutile de préciser que
l'implication est inéluctable et que les
français sondés représenter ou des
représentants il n'est pas non plus bien
utile à ce stade de préciser que la
capacité à repenser la démocratie
améliorera la capacité à faire société
voici comment je réécris ray ce passage
il faut d'abord réfléchir aux raisons
pour lesquelles la démocratie est
aujourd'hui l'objet de controverses
cette réflexion on demande ensuite
d'interroger la capacité des français à
repenser ensemble leur modèle de société
on voit bien avec cette version plus
clair à quel point le second problème
est vague
interrogée la capacité des français à
repenser ensemble leur modèle de société
ouais je me demande comment on va s'y
prendre non on ne voit pas du tout le
problème intellectuel de cette
dissertation donc la problématique est
nul
étant donné les éléments de
problématisation que j'ai lu dans les
paragraphes précédents je formulerai la
problématique de la manière suivante la
représentation et tuft elle vraiment la
démocratie
cette formulation est certes provocante
mais c'est pour stimuler la réflexion et
puissent tout de même je modère cette
hypothèse avec l'adverbe vraiment donc
je ne suis pas en train de suggérer que
les gilets jaunes ont raison c'est même
plutôt le contraire
en conclusion ce paragraphe son s'est
présenté la problématique n'est pas bon
c'est trop vagues trop brouillon et
surtout on n'arrive pas à saisir la
problématique
allez je passe au 5e et dernier
paragraphe de l'introduction
alors ce paragraphe c'est évidemment
l'annnonce de plan il ya le numéro des
grandes parties entre parenthèses je lis
dans un premier temps il conviendra
d'admettre que la démocratie même sous
sa forme représentative est un modèle
légitime qu'il convient de conserver et
ce bien qu'elle fasse l'objet de
contestations dans un second temps il
faudra s'appesantir sur les dérives de
telle contestation
en effet des voix s'élèvent pour que la
démocratie représentative soit
abandonnée au profit d'une démocratie
directe
pourtant la renouveler lui donner un
second souffle à part et peut-être plus
sérieux
je simplifie pour vous le propos de ce
plan il faut conserver la démocratie
malgré les contestations il est plus
sérieux de faire évoluer la démocratie
représentative
plutôt que d'essayer la démocratie
directe c'est un plan ena en deux fois
deux partis grand un grand tas grand un
grand b grand de grand a et grands de
grand baie avec deux arguments dans
chaque sous parties alors avant d'entrer
dans des considérations techniques sur
la méthodologie de la dissertation je
veux dire un mot à propos du fonds la
arthur prend clairement partie il dit
que les contestations des rives et que
la bonne solution la solution la plus
sérieuse c'est de renouveler le modèle
existant j'imagine deux types de
remarques
je pense que certains d'entre vous
doivent se dire hey mais il prend parti
ne devrait pas et puis d'autres parmi
vous se disent peut-être que le propos
est trop conservateur trop sévère avec
les contestations
si vous avez pensé une de ces deux
choses
alors vous manquez de pragmatisme en
rappelez vous qu arthur écrit une
dissertation pour devenir haut
fonctionnaire c'est à dire pour
travailler dans le système existant dans
celui qui il contesté en tant que
démocratie représentative
pour être plus précis il veut devenir un
agent du système de la démocratie
française actuelle et c'est un agent de
cette démocratie le correcteur qui va
juger son travail
je ne dis pas que la démocratie
française actuelle est un mauvais
système
je ne dis pas qu'elle est un bon système
je dis qu'il faut être pragmatique vous
voulez devenir haut fonctionnaire alors
adopté au moins le temps du concours le
logiciel de penser des hauts
fonctionnaires ne fait pas l'éloge du
gilet jaune ne dit pas que l'état
français est probablement la démocratie
occidentale la plus corrompue ne
critiquait pas l'inefficacité de la
bureaucratie
rester dans le cadre du discours
dominant au sein de l'administration
et c'est la même chose si vous passez
d'autres concours vous disserter pour
intégrer une école de commerce ne fait
pas une critique radicale du capitalisme
ne suggéré pas qu'il faut vendre son âme
pour s'enrichir
dans son annonce de plan qui est sa
réponse aux problèmes posés arthur fait
preuve d'intelligence stratégique
il montre aux correcteurs qui pensent
déjà comme lui avec le recul et le cadre
de pensée d'un haut fonctionnaire
oui le système est contesté mais les
contestataires sont dans l'excès et il
ne mesure pas la complexité de la
question
la meilleure solution ce n'est pas la
révolution c'est la réforme c'est de
corriger l'existant en termes de
conformité idéologique
c'est ce qu'il faut faire mais cette
dimension mise à part je trouve le plan
l annonce de plan mauvais le premier
défaut c'est l'ordre des idées je vais
simplifier les idées du plan arthur
première idée la démocratie est un
modèle légitime à conserver
deuxième idée la démocratie vit
actuellement une crise de confiance
troisième idée la démocratie et
contester radicalement quatrième idée il
faut renouveler la démocratie
cet ordre n'est pas bon parce qu'il ne
range pas les idées de la plus évidente
à la moins évidente
petit rappel de méthodologie la
progression de la dissertation doivent
simuler la progression de la réflexion
donc il faut forcément aller du plus
évident les idées qu'on trouve
immédiatement au moins évident les idées
qu'on trouve au bout d'un certain temps
de réflexion en l'occurrence ça n'a pas
de sens de commencer directement en
posant qu'il faut conserver le modèle
actuel de démocratie ces données
immédiatement la solution au problème du
coup ça n'a pas non plus de sens
d'enchaîner avec le constat de la crise
de confiance
il fallait plutôt commencer par ça
puisque c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
évident c'est un diagnostic largement
admis dans l'opinion publique
si je schématise le plan d'arthur
s'adonne défense de la démocratie
constat de la crise critique de la
contestation défense de la réforme
là on réalise que c'est surtout la
première partie qui pose problème
comment passer logiquement de la défense
de la démocratie au constat de la crise
en revanche le passage du constat de la
crise à la critique de la contestation
et naturelle lui la démocratie française
vite
actuellement une crise mais la
contestation est excessive
le passage à la quatrième et dernière
partie fonctionne également
la contestation est excessive c'est
pourquoi la réforme est la meilleure
solution mais bon si j'ai eu besoin de
simplifier les idées dans un premier
temps puis de les schémas tease et dans
un second temps ça veut bien dire qu'il
ya un problème d'expression pour les
deux premières phrases c'est surtout la
forme qui pêchent le verbe convenir ne
sert à rien il fait perdre du temps et
arthur le répète il est inutile de
préciser qu'il convient de conserver un
modèle légitime puisqu'il est légitime
il faut une proposition principale dans
la deuxième phrase pour les trois
dernières phrases c'est surtout le fond
qui pêchent la phrase dans un second
temps il faudra s'appesantir sur les
dérives de dell contestation cette
phrase résume mal le propos du grand 2
en effet la première sous parties ne
parle pas de dérive et la seconde ce
parti parle au contraire des solutions
concernant les idées je distingue mal le
grand 1 b bien qu'elle fasse l'objet de
contestations et le grand 2 il faudra
s'appesantir sur les contestations
arthur va parler des contestations dans
le grand est un bébé du coup je me
demande pourquoi en reparler dans le
grand 2
sinon je pense que le verbe pronominal
s'appesantir n'est pas le bon choix
parce qu'il veut dire développer un
sujet avec excès ou insistance les
verbes étudier ou analyser était plus
juste
je ne suis pas fan non plus de la voix
passive enfin parmi les qualités de
cette annonce de plan il faut souligner
l'effort fait pour fluidifier le passage
avec des mots liaison voici comment je
reformule rel annonces de plans d'arthur
je ne change pas les idées mais
uniquement la formulation la démocratie
est un modèle légitime
quoi qu'elle fasse l'objet de
contestations seulement celle-ci
accouche du projet radical de l'abandon
de la représentation
c'est pourquoi un renouvellement du
modèle français semble nécessaire c'est
déjà plus clair mais la faiblesse des
idées se ressent encore dans la forme
je vais donc vous dire le plan que
j'aurais fait pour traiter ce sujet
alors ma problématique c'était la
représentation et tuft elle vraiment la
démocratie
j'aurais répondu à cette question de la
manière suivante la démocratie française
semble vivre une crise dont un grand a
en effet la dimension démocratique du
système représentatif serait illusoire
à en croire la contestation dont un
grand baie si cette critique paraître
excessive eu égard au succès du modèle
français grande grand a
elle invite cependant à le renouveler
dans un sens plus démocratique grand de
grand baie voilà voilà j'en ai terminé
avec l'introduction de cette
dissertation
je vais maintenant regarder la
conclusion arthur a rédigé un seul
paragraphe de conclusion ça c'est bien
en termes de taille et c'est suffisant
quatre longues phrases mais disons que
c'est la limite basse pour une
dissertation de 12 pages
les trois première phrase résume le
propos de la dissertation et la
quatrième est une ouverture
alors je les ai déjà dix ans plusieurs
vidéos n'essayez pas décrire une
ouverture ce n'est pas un effort
rentable l'exercice de la dissertation
est suffisamment difficile comme ça si
vous voulez en savoir plus regardez la
vidéo sur la conclusion en l'occurrence
c'est plutôt réussi
mais arthur aurait pu consacrer des
ressources intellectuelles et le temps
qu'il a investi pour trouver et rédiger
cette ouverture
ils auraient pu les consacrés à
l'amélioration de son introduction
alors je sais que les correcteurs
regarde la conclusion rapidement mais je
vais quand même la lyre phrase par
phrase parce que c'est intéressant
première phrase deux cent trente ans
après le duel et cs contre rousseau la
démocratie et sa nature font encore
débat dans la société contemporaine en
france comme ailleurs est
particulièrement à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
c'est plutôt une bonne phrase pour
commencer la conclusion mais j'ai déjà
dit ce qu'il faut penser du duel seyes
contre le rousseau
moi j'aurais simplement fait référence à
la croche
ça aurait créé un bel effet d'en parler
à la fois où tout début et à la toute
fin de la dissertation
sinon la phrase est claire petit détail
les guillemets angle deuxième phrase
légitime est contestée celle ci est
aussi menacée par des formes radicales
aujourd'hui hautement visible en fluo
sur la forme phrases plus courtes 17 mo
que la précédente qui faisait 35 mots
c'est une bonne chose pour le rythme
elle est très claire sur le fond elle
résume une grande idée du développement
la démocratie est contestée bien qu'elle
soit légitime
d'accord après je trouve que la
référence au gilet jaune et de trop
arthur en a déjà parlé dans
l'introduction là ça commence à
ressembler à une obsession un haut
fonctionnaire doit manifester le
détachement qu'ici à la défense de
l'intérêt général
après si on lit bien à la suite les deux
premières phrases de cette conclusion on
se rend compte qu arthur a commis une
erreur d'expression le pronom
démonstratif
celle ci désigne la démocratie mais le
mot est trop éloignée pour qu'on
comprenne bien normalement celle ci
désigne l'union européenne moi j'aurais
écrit le modèle français est aussi
menacé j'aurais également pu répéter le
nom commun démocratie parce que les
répétitions sont utiles lorsqu elles
permettent d'éviter l'ambiguïté
l'expression d'arthur est globalement
efficace mais il ya tout de même des
erreurs troisième phrase renouveler la
démocratie apparaît alors comme un
impératif autant que de s'étonner qu'une
partie de la population se contentent de
dénoncer sans participer la construction
est un peu compliqué il faut renouveler
la démocratie et il faut tout autant
s'étonner que ceux qui dénoncent ne
participe pas il y a deux idées dans
cette phrase
moi je rêve inversé leurs ordres et je
les aurai opposé je trouve que c'est
plus simple
ça pourrait donner s'il faut s'étonner
qu'une partie de la population se
contentent de dénoncer sans participer
cette critique invite toutefois à
renouveler la démocratie après la phrase
d'arthur est globalement claire
quatrième et dernière phrase comme aime
à le dire l'écrivain et aventurier
sylvain tesson dans son ouvrage bérézina
la france est un paradis peuplé de gens
qui se croient en enfer alors il ya
plusieurs choses à dire
premièrement hemera signifie prendre
plaisir à quelque chose ce qui
présuppose une répétition par exemple gm
à corriger des copies de concours je
peux le dire parce que je l' ai déjà
fait et parce que je compte leur faire à
l'avenir
ici il n'ya pas de répétition parce que
c'est une citation tirée d'un bouquin
ensuite inutile de préciser que sylvain
tesson est écrivain et aventurier parce
que le correcteur le sait vous écrivez
pour votre lecteur du coup il était tout
autant inutile de préciser que bérézina
est un ouvrage il suffisait d'écrire
comme l'écrit sylvain tesson dans
bérézina la france est un paradis peuplé
de gens qui se croient en enfer et puis
il faut des guillemets français sur le
fond la citation arrive à point nommé
arthur vient de relativiser la
légitimité de la contestation
et il termine en disant grosso modo on
est quand même bien en france pourquoi
pas mais cet optimisme me paraît
excessif
bien sûr que tout n'est pas noir en
france bien sûr que les contestataires
ont intérêt à noircir le tableau mais de
là à finir la dissertation ou disons que
la france est un paradis c'est certes
une ouverture simple et efficace
c'est une bonne punchline mais ça peut
donner l'impression que le candidat
abandonne l'objectivité qu'on attend
d'un haut fonctionnaire mue par le
service de l'intérêt général
moi j'aurais plutôt relativiser les
choses en rappelant que la france est un
pays révolutionnaire avec une vie
politique
historiquement agitée enfin moi je
n'aurais pas fait d'ouverture
alors je sais que c'était long mais
l'introduction elle-même été longue et
il y avait beaucoup de choses à dire
puis c'est un sujet intéressant qu'est
ce que j'en pense en synthèse de
l'introduction et la conclusion d'
arthur lee trois principaux défauts de
l'introduction se sont tout d'abord la
confusion des enjeux au lieu de se
concentrer sur un seul et unique en jeu
par paragraphe arthur s'emmêle les
pinceaux
parce qu'il veut trop en faire et
probablement parce qu'il veut montrer
qu'il a beaucoup de connaissances sur la
démocratie deuxième principal défaut de
l'introduction la problématisation est
ratée à tuer n'explique pas clairement
comment il en arrive aux problèmes
intellectuels qu'il va résoudre dans la
dissertation et puis je n'ai pas non
plus réussi à identifier instantanément
et facilement le problème en question
troisième principal défaut de
l'introduction la définition des termes
n'est pas efficace déjà parlé il
suffisait de donner l'étymologie du mot
démocratie puis d'opposer l'idéal et ses
applications concrètes
ce qui permettait d'arriver à la
différence entre la démocratie directe
et la démocratie représentative
voilà pour les trois principaux défauts
après il ya aussi des imprécisions des
répétitions quelques erreurs
d'expression mais rien de grave
les trois principales qualités
maintenant tout d'abord j'ai bien aimé
le paragraphe d'across le trouve
efficace
ensuite le style est efficace et je le
trouve même plutôt dynamique c'est un
bon point parce que ça rend la lecture
moins pénible troisième principale
qualité
l'effort de structuration l'introduction
alors je mentionne cette qualité en
troisième parce qu'elle est quand même
gâché par la confusion des enjeux à
l'intérieur des paragraphes voilà en
conclusion je suis déçu je me suis pris
la tête plusieurs fois en lisant cette
introduction
donc elles manquent de clarté quant à la
conclusion de la dissertation
elle fait le job elle est plutôt courte
et elle dit que la france est un paradis
mais bon ce n'est pas grave
alors maintenant que j'ai lu
attentivement l'introduction et la
conclusion de la dissertation d'arthur
je peux si tu es plus précisément la
copie dans une fourchette de notes à mes
yeux le propos est trop confus pour
mériter plus de 14
mais je ne peux pas imaginer mettre
moins
10 ce serait trop sévère c'est quand
même une dissertation bien rédigé avec
des qualités réelles
donc bon à ce stade je me dis que je
mettrais entre 10 et 14 je vais dire le
développement de la dissertation pour
décider de la note finale je vais le
lire comme un correcteur de concours
enfin moins superficiellement quand même
je vais surtout lire les introductions
et les conclusions partielles les
arguments et les introductions de
référence allez c'est parti
[Musique]
alors titre du grand teint la démocratie
débattu entre légitimité et contestation
pourquoi pas pour une dissertation et
dijon 1 5 heures c'est un titre efficace
ne peut pas demander la lune non plus on
comprend assez bien l'idée du grand
teint la démocratie est un modèle qui a
fait ses preuves
bien qu'ils soient contestées sur la
forme le titre est simple et claire en
revanche je trouve que l'annoncent d2
son parti est trop compliqué pas besoin
de trois phrases ni de cité churchill
pour présenter le grand 1 a comme je les
dis à propos de l'introduction il faut
dire des choses intéressantes au bon
endroit mêmes reproches pour la
présentation du grand baie mieux vaut se
concentrer sur une seule idée en
l'occurrence l'échec de l'identification
représenter représentants après cette
introduction partielle est plutôt
efficace
mais le problème est que la méthode
n'est probablement pas réplicable c'est
la question que j'ai posée arthur
serait-il vraiment capable de gérer
cette complexité de discours pour
disserter sur un sujet difficile qui
demande un effort de réflexion supérieur
je ne suis pas certain
sur le plan du style c'est clair et les
phrases courtes dynamisait l'expression
attention il ya encore une erreur de
prénom
quel est le nom que remplace ce elle
forme représentative parti démocratie
ici il fallait répéter le bon nom pour
écrire clairement c'est simple il faut
supprimer l'ambiguïté
le lecteur ne doit pas pouvoir résister
je continue titre du grand art
la légitimité de la démocratie un modèle
viable
sur le fond c'est pertinent la
démocratie est un modèle viable parce
qu'elle a passé l'épreuve du temps
même s'ils ont pour répondre que deux
siècles ce n'est pas non plus l'éternité
l'échelle de l'espèce humaine
sur le plan de l'expression on comprend
mais j'aurais plutôt décrit la
légitimité de la démocratie sa viabilité
ensuite arthur introduit là sous parties
ça fait peut-être beaucoup une
introduction partielle n'est c'est une
bonne chose sur le plan de la
méthodologie parce que ces passages
permettent d'accompagner le correcteur
qui le lecteur dans le raisonnement le
problème avec cette introduction
partielle c'est qu'une fois de plus
arthur compliquer les choses plutôt que
de m'accompagner dans son raisonnement
il me fournit de nouvelles connaissances
et il répète certaines idées
l'introduction de la démocratie dans
l'histoire politique française
l'impossibilité de la démocratie directe
le consensus sur la stabilité du régime
démocratique
c'est trop long et trop compliqué à quoi
bon préciser ici par exemple que la
monarchie est une tradition aussi
française qu'européenne
une fois de plus la complexité entre un
arthur à commettre des erreurs
les révolutionnaires ne sont pas les
successeurs des lumières parce que les
révolutionnaires sont des hommes tandis
que les lumières sont un mouvement
culturel et je pourrai encore souligné
d'autres défauts pour introduire cette
sous parties il suffisait de se
concentrer sur une seule idée le modèle
démocratique a passé l'épreuve du temps
ouais c'est toujours efficace sur le
plan du style allez je regarde le tout
premier paragraphe du développement de
cette dissertation première phrase en
premier lieu la démocratie est le régime
que la france a adopté en 1789
sur le fond cet argument n'est pas bon
le fait que la france est adopté le
régime démocratique en 1789 nous montre
pas que ce régime est viable ça ne
contribue donc pas à résoudre le
problème intellectuel
l'idée pertinente à mon avis c'est
plutôt que la démocratie a remplacé un
régime qui n'était plus viable
la monarchie donc arthur vise à côté dès
le début de l'argumentation
il me donne l'impression de préparer un
déballage de connaissances en revanche
la rédaction et efficace la phrase est
courte et claire dans les cinq phrases
suivantes
il explique que les révolutionnaires ont
hésité entre les deux conceptions direct
ou représentative de la démocratie dans
les quatre suivantes
il explique que la conception
représentative a été retenue pour des
raisons non pas idéologique mais
pratique
il y a trop de citoyens dans un grand
état et puis les gens n'ont pas beaucoup
de temps à consacrer à la politique
c'est en réalité la dernière phrase du
paragraphe qui fournit l'argument même
si elles ciblent mal l'idée cette idée
c'est la démocratie directe semble
impossible à mettre en place dans un
grand état du coup par élimination c'est
la démocratie représentative qui est
viable est donc légitime que dire
d'autre à propos de ce premier
paragraphe
ça se lit facilement c'est fluide
notamment grâce aux mots de liaison
arthur rappelle une fois de plus le
débat entre rousseau essayait ce soit
il oublie de souligner la référence de
la démocratie en amérique
et il précise inutilement que c'est un
ouvrage il ne développe pas assez cette
référence une seule phrase c'est
vraiment trop peu ce qu'il fallait faire
s'est présenté l'argument la démocratie
directe semble impossible à mettre en
place dans un grand état
les expliquer en quelques phrases et
enfin évoqué de la démocratie en
amérique en quelques phrases pour donner
plus de crédit à l'argument enfin je
remarque aussi quelques détails le style
d'arthur et parfois un peu
journalistique
il écrit des phrases sans proposition
principale ils utilisent encore des
guillemets anglais en conclusion ce
paragraphe est mauvais sur le plan de
l'alimentation et l'organisation du
propos et maladroite
je passe au paragraphe suivant en second
lieu la démocratie est considérée ou au
moins peut l'être comme un régime
relativement stable première chose
arthur structure le grand 1 à très
simplement avec les liens logiques
d'énumération en premier lieu et en
second lieu pas de la grande littérature
mais c'est efficace
c'est facile à lire sur le fond cet
argument et pertinents l'idée de la
stabilité de la démocratie montre bien
que c'est un modèle viable ce qui est
l'idée du grand art
arthur présente cet argument avec
modération
la démocratie peut être considérée comme
un régime relativement stable alors
c'est bien mais l'expression est un peu
maladroite en particulier la locution ou
au moins peut l'être
moi j'aurais écrit plus simplement en
second lieu le régime démocratique jouit
d'une relative stabilité remarqué aussi
que le passage à la voix active améliore
instantanément l'expression écrit après
la phrase d'arthur et quand même clair
c'est moi qui suis un maniaque du style
dans les deux phrases suivantes
il cadre historiquement sa démonstration
il dit regardons les trois derniers
république dans les phrases 4 5 et 6 ils
expliquent la stabilité du modèle
français par son caractère composite
l'idée derrière c'est que c'est un
modèle mieux adapté à la réalité
c'est pour ça qu'il serait durable la
référence aux principes du gouvernement
représentatif de bernard manin un
ouvrage de référence sur le thème de la
démocratie cette référence et 3 pas
l'usi ve dans les phrases 7 à 10 il
introduit une seconde référence les 60
ans de la constitution et il s'en sert
pour apporter du crédit à son argument
mieux vaut mobiliser une seule référence
par paragraphe du développement mais là
c'est bien sur le plan de la méthode au
parc arthur mobilise une référence
pertinente et parce qu'il prend soin de
la développer la 11e et dernière phrase
du paragraphe en rappel est l'idée
directrice c'est bien mais le style est
journalistique à mon goût l'expression
écrite est toujours efficace dans ce
paragraphe
les phrases s'enchaînent plutôt bien
grâce aux mots liaison arthur commet une
grosse faute d'orthographe
le souligner puisque les ouvrages à deux
auteurs il ya encore deux petites
imperfections mais le correcteur n'y
fera pas attention mise à part la
mobilisation de deux références je
trouve que c'est un paragraphe efficace
sur le plan de l'argumentation
arthur présente une idée précise qui va
dans le sens de celle de la sueur partie
puis ils l'expliquent clairement il
termine là sous partie avec une
transition néanmoins la démocratie est
aujourd'hui l'objet de sérieuses
contestation le débat qui opposait cis
et rousseau est relancé avec force et
c'est simple et c'est tease le grand 1 b
le rappel du débat c'est yes rousseau
est un peu irritant mais bon la
transition et efficace arthur accompagné
le correcteur jusqu'à la prochaine étape
de son raisonnement c'est bien
allez je passe à lassouts parties
suivantes titre de ce grand un bep la
démocratie contester la crise de
confiance ces cours est très clair ça me
plaît
introduction partielle de ce grand 1 b
aujourd'hui une partie de la population
française ne se sent plus représenté
elle n'a plus confiance en ses
représentants la démocratie dans sa
forme représentative est alors contesté
et à cet égard ce sentiment a été
exacerbé par les nouveaux moyens de
diffusion de l'information tels que les
réseaux sociaux lesquels participent à
renforcer la crise de confiance envers
les décideurs publics
les deux premières phrases répète une
énième fois des idées qu'on connaît
depuis l'introduction et la troisième
introduit ce qui sera j'imagine
l'argument du second paragraphe de la
seule partie honnêtement c'est trop
compliqué c'est très bien d'accompagner
le correcteur mais il faut le faire
simplement
l'objectif c'est uniquement de lui
fournir des points de repère il est
inutile de répéter 15 fois les mêmes
idées ou d'introduire une première fois
les arguments avant les paragraphes du
développement pour introduire ce grand à
un b moi je me bornerai à dire que la
technologie amplifie un sentiment de la
conscience collective
ce sera ensuite au paragraphe de
préciser cette idée générale sinon le
style est toujours efficace dans ce
paragraphe
je trouve juste que l'allocution est à
cet égard créer un lien artificiel est
plutôt maladroit allez je passe au 1er
paragraphe de cette sous parties alors
première phrase
tout d'abord la démocratie est
aujourd'hui l'objet de contestation
d'une partie de la population
est ce que vous voyez le problème avec
cette idée
le problème et c'est qu'elle est au même
niveau de généralité que celle de l'asu
partie le grand 1 b c'est que la
démocratie est contestée est le premier
argument de ce grand un b c'est que la
démocratie est contestée donc ça ne va
pas il fallait une idée plus précise
j'ajoute qu'arthur a répété je ne sais
combien de fois depuis l'introduction
l'idée que la démocratie est contestée
rien que dans cette sous parties on la
retrouve dans le titre dans
l'introduction partielle et dans le
premier argument
en fait la véritable idée de l'argument
arrive à la phrase suivante un profond
sentiment d'injustice anime certains
citoyens et c'est pourquoi la démocratie
française est-elle contestée parce que
certains citoyens ou le sentiment
qu'elle est injuste c'est donc bien
cette idée
l'argument du parec les phrases 2 et 3
disent que le sentiment d'injustice vise
les professionnels de la politique
la suite du paragraphe explique la
dérive de ce sentiment
les phrases 4 5 et 6 disent qu'ils
créent un climat de défiance qui empêche
les français de prendre leur destin en
main arthur mobilise une référence
classique dans les concours de la
fonction publique mais il introduit mal
le verbe arrive trop tard il ne la
développe pas à ces deux phrases c'est
trop peu et il commet une grosse faute
d'orthographe
encore une fois il ya deux auteurs donc
c'est dénonce event et ensuite les
phrases 7 8 9 et 10 défend l'idée que la
dérive du sentiment d'injustice culmine
dans le complotisme artio mobilise une
seconde référence savez ce que j'en
pense mais il la développe mieux que la
première
enfin la 11e et dernière phrase de ce
paragraphe opère la transition vers
l'idée du paragraphe suivant les réseaux
sociaux amplifie la dérive du sentiment
d'injustice
alors au global ce paragraphe est
moyennement réussi l'argument n'est pas
présenté clairement dans la première
phrase le début du paragraphe est raté
mais l'idée est pertinente
je trouve aussi que l'idée de la
corruption du sentiment d'injustice en
défiance généralisée d'abord puis en
complotisme je trouve que cette idée est
efficace pour développer l'argument
autre défaut arthur mobilise encore de
référence après l'expression écrite est
efficace dans le paragraphe notamment
grâce aux liens logiques
globalement c'est dommage les idées sont
intéressantes
le paragraphe est plutôt cohérent mais
l'argumentation manque de rigueur
je passe au paragraphe suivant première
phrase ensuite et en effet le sentiment
de distance entre représentants et
représentés est exacerbée par
l'utilisation irréfléchie des réseaux
sociaux sur le fond arthur se répète
puisque il y a voulu annoncer cet
argument à la fin du par ailleurs
précédent il a déjà dit que les réseaux
sociaux amplifie la contestation
maintenant il dit que les réseaux
sociaux amplifie le sentiment d'une
distance entre les représenter et les
représentants n'a pas gagné grand chose
en termes de sens il ya trop de redites
dans cette dissertation parce que le
déploiement de l'argumentation n'est pas
assez rigoureux là par exemple il
suffisait de présenter l'idée de
l'argument une seule fois au début du
second paragraphe sur le fond toujours
je trouve que parler du l'utilisation
irréfléchie des réseaux sociaux est à la
fois vague un peu condescendant
c'est quoi une utilisation y réfléchit
moi je me serais contenté de dire que
les réseaux sociaux amplifie le
sentiment de défiance des représenté à
l'égard des représentants sur la forme
l'allocution est en effet n'est pas
terrible elle n'apporte pas grand chose
et elle nuit à la fluidité de la lecture
la structure tout d'abord ensuite est
certes basique mais c'est suffisant pour
une sous-partie subdivisée en deux
arguments enfin toujours sur la forme
j'aurais également tourné la phrase à la
voix active l'utilisation irréfléchie
des réseaux sociaux exacerbe et c'est la
deuxième phrase répète une énième fois
que c'est le principe de la
représentation qui est visé par les
critiques
les phrases 3 4 et 5 disent que les
réseaux sociaux peuvent créer une
pression démocratique dans les pays
autoritaires
là je ne vois pas à quoi ça sert de
consacrer trois phrases et une référence
à l'idée contraire de celle qu arthur
est censé défendre
il aurait pu mentionner cet effet en
passant mais là il en parle trop je
pense qu'il a commis cette erreur parce
qu'il n'avait pas de matière pour
crédibiliser son argument en outre une
fois de plus ils ne développent pas
assez la référence les phrases 6 7 et 8
reviennent à l'argument du paragraphe et
le défendre avec l'exemple du fake news
c'est beaucoup trop court
c'est tout au long du paragraphe qu'il
fallait expliquer éprouvé l'idée selon
laquelle les réseaux sociaux creuse le
fossé de confiance entre les représenter
et les représentants
la phrase 9 répète comme la deuxième
phrase l'idée que c'est le principe de
la représentation qui est visé par les
critiques
d'ailleurs allez deux phrases sont
identiques à un mot près sur le plan du
style l'expression est efficace et
fluide en particulier dans ce paragraphe
les phrases sont bien connecté
explicitement les unes aux autres
l'alternance entre phrases longues et
phrases courtes créer du dynamisme
en revanche je déplore l' usage de la
voix passive et les guillemets anglais
on arrive à la conclusion partielle du
grand temps dans la première phrase
arthur répète une énième fois que la
démocratie est contestée
si le correcteur ne l'a pas compris
c'est qu'il est amnésique
arthur reprend sa référence à churchill
pourquoi pas ça crée une impression de
cohérence l'idée qui est intéressant
pour la transition arrive à la deuxième
phrase la diversité et la conflictuelle
it et des opinions est normal en
démocratie c'est la radicalité de la
contestation qui pose problème
cette conclusion partielle et efficace
parce qu'elle amène bien la prochaine
grande idée
alors j'en ai terminé avec la grande
partie qu'est ce que je peux en dire
pour faire synthétique je vais énumérer
les trois principaux défauts et les
trois principales qualités de cette
première grande partie le premier
principal défaut c'est la pertinence de
l'argumentation
normalement chaque paragraphe doit
commencer par une idée précise qui sert
approuvé l'idée plus générale de la
partie hors sas est souvent raté le
deuxième principal défaut c'est la
cohérence des paragraphes
je vous ai dit la bonne démarche pour
rédiger un paragraphe c'est de présenter
une idée de développer puis de
l'illustré hors arthur ne procède pas
comme ça c'est confus il part dans une
direction dans une autre puis il revient
dans le second paragraphe du grandes
baies il défend même l'idée inverse de
celle de l'argument le troisième
principal défaut de cette première
grande partie c'est plus généralement le
manque de rigueur de l'argumentation
arthur mélange les idées précises avec
les idées générales les connaissances
avec les arguments les introductions
partiel avec les arguments bref en
termes de méthode hausse est trop confus
maintenant quelles sont les trois
principales qualités de cette première
grande partie la première à mes yeux
c'est l'expression c'est quand même
vraiment claire et fluide ça c'est un
très bon point la deuxième principale
qualité c'est l'impression de pertinence
qui se dégage mine de rien en répétant
systématiquement les mêmes idées arthur
me donne l'impression qu'il est
absolument focaliser sur le sujet qu'il
traite le sujet et rien que le sujet
enfin la troisième principale qualité de
ce grand 1 c'est la qualité des
connaissances arthur connaît bien son
cours et peut-être trop bien d'ailleurs
parce qu'il a du mal à s'en détacher
pour se focaliser sur la qualité de
l'argumentation
à mes yeux il veut trop en faire il
fournit trop d'informations alors que
l'enjeu est de sélectionner les
informations pertinentes pour convaincre
le lecteur à ce stade de ma correction
je suis déçu
trouve que c'est trop confus même s'il
ya bien sûr des qualités en terme de
notation je penche plutôt vers le 10
mais bon je vais peut-être encore
changer d'avis allez on se plonge dans
la seconde grande partie de la
dissertation
[Musique]
alors regardons un peu le titre du grand
de la démocratie en péril de la dérive à
l'apaisement c'est très clair mais il ya
un problème sur le fond l'idée de péril
ne synthétisent pas le passage de la
dérive à l'apaisement d'ailleurs ce
passage ne s'est pas produit et la
dissertation d'arthur ne fait que
préconisée l'apaisement pour remédier à
la radicalisation de la contestation
l'allocution de la dérive à l'apaisement
est donc trompeuse mois j'écrirai plutôt
la démocratie en péril la nécessité de
l'apaisement
regardons maintenant l'annoncent dé son
parti
elle est un peu moins compliquée que
celle du grand art mais c'est encore
trop compliqué à mon la structure de la
première phrase est maladroite les
contestations tenante à la
représentation sont aujourd'hui tels que
d'aucuns revendiquent la nécessité de
passer à une démocratie directe
on peut dire bien plus simplement que la
contestation de la représentation abouti
à la défense de la démocratie directe
mais je pense que le plus simple était
encore de fusionner les deux premières
phrases ce qui donnerait quelque chose
comme la défense de la démocratie
directe occulte le véritable enjeu
l'amélioration de la représentativité la
troisième phrase celle qui introduit le
b est elle claire jeu-là tournerait
juste à la voix active les citoyens
semblent d'attendre un renouvellement
etc
les deuxième et troisième phrase de ce
paragraphe sont bien claires la première
à l'est un peu moins comme je les dis
sur le fond il ya bien sûr des partis
pris idéologiques
la revendication de la démocratie
directe ne constitue pas en elle-même
une dérive
mais un haut fonctionnaire d'une
démocratie représentative le pensent
probablement et puis c'est maladroit de
dire qu'on doit renouveler la démocratie
pour apaiser la population
on doit surtout la renouveler pour
l'améliorer et si l'amélioration est
réel les citoyens seront satisfaits mais
bon ce sont des détails
ça montre que c'est un sujet un peu
cheap par les temps qui courent et qu'il
fallait faire preuve d'une certaine
habileté politique
de ce point de vue arthur a été plutôt
bon il a dit aux correcteurs des choses
qu'il est prête à entendre
regardons maintenant le titre du à la
dérive
la démocratie et 20 c'est bon c'est très
court et très clair mais je trouve que
l'adjectif évincé est excessif
la démocratie est bien contester mais
elle n'a pas été vaincue le système
représentatif français est toujours en
place il fonctionne toujours
j'aurais plutôt écrit la démocratie
menacée et encore ensuite arthur
introduit là sous parties en deux
phrases je trouve qu'il aurait pu s'en
passer parce que ces deux phrases
n'apporte rien la première répète l'idée
la radicalité de la contestation et la
secondaire répète l'idée selon laquelle
la contestation radicale est à côté du
vrai problème qui est l'effectivité de
la représentation et non pas la
démocratie elle même
j'ajoute qu'il y à une maladresse
d'expression dans chaque phrase qu'elle
soit idéologiques voire physique il
fallait écrire ou physiques et mais le
cadre dans lequel il y en a à résoudre
cette proposition n'est pas clair encore
moins si on la lit rapidement
donc bon l'introduction partielle n'est
pas terrible allez je regarde le premier
paragraphe du grand deux premières
phrases d'une part la démocratie telle
qu'elle existe aujourd'hui sous sa forme
représentative en france est ébranlé par
une partie de la population qui désirent
l'avoir dirais donc arthur commence avec
l'argument selon lequel la revendication
de la démocratie directe ébranle le
système français actuel c'est un bon
argument
mais la forme n'est pas bonne déjà la
phrase est trop longue
27 mo pour commencer le paragraphe c'est
parce que la construction est trop
lourde
la démocratie telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui sous sa forme représentative
en france
et puis une partie de la population qui
désirent l'avoir direct je trouve aussi
que la présentation de l'idée manque de
modération
on peut écrire bien plus simplement
d'une part la revendication de la
démocratie directe semble ébranler le
système français actuel ce n'est pas
utile de préciser qu'une partie de la
population veut la démocratie directe
parce que ça reste vague enfin commencer
par le connecteur logique d'une part
c'est pas mal sa structure clairement le
propos et puis ça change
les phrases deux à cinq ne constitue pas
un développement pertinent parce qu'elle
montre que le système démocratique
actuel est déjà en partie directe ça ne
prouve pas que la revendication de la
démocratie directe et brand le système
français actuel c'est le même problème
de rigueur de la réglementation que dans
le grand bain j'ajoute que la deuxième
phrase relève d'un style journalistique
il faut une proposition principale
les phrases 6 7 8 et 9 10 que
l'ignorance des contestataires
ils ignorent les opportunités de
démocratie directe du système actuel
leur ignorance favorise le populisme ce
développement est pertinent par rapport
à l'argument parce que le populisme
ébranle le système politique actuel
cependant encore une fois arthur ne
développe pas assez la référence et je
trouve aussi que l'interprétation du
populisme qu'il présente n'est pas très
subtil les figures charismatiques
veulent gagner les voix et attiser les
conflits en outre arthur donne encore
dans le style journalistique en écrivant
deux phrases nominales à la suite pour
récupérer des voix pour attiser les
conflits dernière phrase répète l'idée
selon laquelle la contestation radicale
passe à côté du vrai problème
en conclusion ce paragraphe présent
qu'il mêmes défauts que ceux du grand
teint l'argumentation manque de rigueur
le propos de cohérence la référence est
insuffisamment développée l'expression
est toujours globalement efficace et
particulièrement fluide grâce au mode
liaison mais la formulation de
l'argument est raté je passe au
paragraphe suivant
première phrase d'autre part évincer la
démocratie telle que celle appliquée en
france c'est-à-dire représentative au
profit d'une démocratie directe ne peut
être opportun et constitue peut-être
même un leurre comme celle du paragraphe
précédent cette première phrase est trop
compliqué la formulation et lourdes
telles que celles appliquées en france
c'est-à-dire représentative ne peut être
opportun et constitue peut-être même un
leurre elle manque aussi de modération
et cela d'autant plus que le sujet est
controversé
sur le fond c'est trop vague
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ne peut être
opportun et constitue peut-être même un
leurre en fait quel est le problème avec
la revendication de la démocratie
directe
viens arthur l'a dit à la fin du
paragraphe précédent
les contestataires défendent un projet
radical alors qu'il y a déjà beaucoup à
espérer du renouvellement de la
démocratie représentative
si on la cible bien l'idée c'est que le
projet du passage à la démocratie
directe est trop risqué voici comment
moi je formulerai l'argument d'autre
part le projet du passage à la
démocratie directe par et risque la
deuxième phrase explique que c'est un
problème de personne pas de système la
troisième affirme que le système actuel
est une conquête à préserver la 4e dit
qu'il faut tolérer les critiques du
système français mais pas aveuglément
avec la 5ème phrase on a droit à un
point godwin en substance si on est trop
soft avec les adversaires de la
démocratie représentative
on déroule le tapis rouge à hitler la
arthur consacre une seule et unique
phrase à la référence qui mobilise c'est
littéralement du name dropping en plus
ce n'est pas super pertinents comme le
révèle le lien logique
à cet égard qui est superficiel mais bon
on lit hitler donc l'esprit critique se
met en veille
la sixième et dernière phrase répète que
le projet du passage à la démocratie
directe est trop radical
deux petites remarques d'expression on
utilise le pronom d'aucun lorsqu'il est
vraiment difficile d'identifier les
agents est plutôt en début de phrase là
moi je parlerai des contestataires
seconde petite remarque il faut écrire
réfléchir à la façon parce que l'objet
de la réflexion est plutôt précis on
réfléchit à un problème on réfléchit sur
sa vie mais moi je préfère dire
réfléchir à dans tous les cas en
conclusion ce second paragraphe n'est
pas terrible comme dans le premier
l'argumentation n'est pas clair dont
celui ci la référence n'est pas du tout
développés
arthur répète des idées qu'il a déjà
évoqué plus haut dans la dissertation
enfin ce paragraphe est court six
phrases contre jusqu'à 12 phrase dans le
grand teint ce n'est pas une bonne chose
de paraître de moins en moins inspiré au
fur et à mesure que le correcteur avance
dans la copie je regarde la conclusion
partielle
arthur l'a écrite à larache elle est
plus courte que les conclusions
partielles précédente et le propos est
maladroit la succession des adjectifs
renversé évincés ou conspué et
désordonnée et puis un système politique
ne peut pas être conspué car conspué ça
veut dire publiquement une personne ou
un groupe de personnes quant à la
seconde phrase c'est alors parlé d'
apaisement
elle n'a pas de sens l'idée précise
c'est que le renouvellement de la
démocratie française aura un effet
apaisant sur les tensions sociales
ou bien qu'on a intérêt à renouveler le
système actuel dans le but d'apaiser les
tensions sociales
mais bon je pense qu arthur a écrit dans
l'urgence je passe à la partie b voici
le titre l'apaisement la démocratie
renouvelée ne sais pas pourquoi arthur
veut à tout prix par les d'apaisement
l'apaisement ce n'est pas ce dont il
s'agit l'apaisement c'est l'effet
hypothétique du renouvellement du
système politique français
moi j'aurais écrit comme titre le
nécessaire renouvellement de la
démocratie
regardons maintenant l'introduction
partielle du grand 2b alors arthur
présente deux solutions solutions numéro
un le personnel politique doit regagner
la confiance des français
solution numéro 2 les citoyens doivent
réfléchir à leurs propres
responsabilités politiques
l'idée de la première solution est
claire mais la formulation et maladroite
une responsabilité consistant à
permettre un regain il suffisait
d'écrire d'un côté les décideurs publics
doivent regagner la confiance des
citoyens
quant à la seconde solution celle
inverse
la formulation est plutôt clair mais
l'idée est vague qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement s'interroger sur son
rôle dans la cité au moins on peut
mesurer l'application de la première
solution il suffira de faire les mêmes
sondages avant et après
sinon la mise en balance des deux
solutions avec la construction d'un côté
de l'autre est efficace voici comment
moi je formulerai cette introduction
partielle dans le côté les représentants
doivent regagner la confiance des
représentants de l'autre les citoyens
doivent aussi réfléchir à leur propre
responsabilité dans le vivre ensemble
allez je regarde le premier paragraphe
de cette partie première phrase
premièrement la démocratie pourra
peut-être être mieux acceptée est
considéré à sa juste valeur par les
français si leurs représentants
poursuivre leurs efforts tendant à
réinstaurer la confiance bon arthur
répète et encore moins clairement la
même idée que trois lignes plus haut les
représentants doivent regagner la
confiance des français
c'est bien d'accompagner le lecteur dans
le raisonnement
mais là une fois de plus c'est trop
pour éviter cette redite moi j'aurais
simplifiée l'introduction partielle de
cette partie en disant que le
renouvellement de la démocratie
française est à la fois de la
responsabilité des représentants et des
représentés et ensuite j'aurai préciser
l'idée dans la première phrase du
premier paragraphe en disant que la
responsabilité des représentants
c'est de regagner la confiance des
citoyens sur la forme maintenant arthur
introduit son argument avec le
connecteur logique d'énumération
premièrement c'est basique mais simple
et efficace
mais la phrase est trop longue 28 mo et
sa construction trop lourde inutile
d'ajouter considéré à sa juste valeur
après mieux acceptée c'est presque une
répétition vide et puis leurs efforts
tendant à réinstaurer la confiance c'est
lourd pour améliorer la formulation de
cette phrase je la passerai à la voix
active
premièrement les français connaîtront
davantage la valeur de leur démocratie
si leurs représentants regagnent leur
confiance dans les phrases ii et iii
arthur introduit une première référence
elle est très pertinente mais elle
arrive trop tôt et il ne la développe
pas assez il n'y consacrent que deux
phrases je vous rappelle qu'en
dissertation il faut expliquer
l'argument sur quelques phrases avant de
mobiliser une connaissance la 4e phrase
dit que la solution de luc rouban et
limiter les phrases 5 et 6 disent que
l'état français s'attèle déjà au
problème de la représentativité dans la
6ème phrase arthur introduit une seconde
référence en mode ninja p la huitième et
dernière phrase du paragraphe opère la
transition vers l'idée du paragraphe
suivant le citoyen a lui aussi une
responsabilité
erreur d'expression chaque citoyen ne
peut pas s'interroger collectivement il
faut plutôt écrire que les citoyens
doivent s'interroger à la fois chacun
personnellement et collectivement bon
que dire de ce paragraphe je n'en pense
pas beaucoup de bien d'abord la
présentation de l'argument est raté et
puis arthur n'explique pas son argument
autre défaut il mobilise deux références
de manière très allusif sur le plan de
l'expression écrite
ça reste efficace comme dans les parties
précédentes de la dissertation
à part peut-être la première phrase
c'est facile à lire et fluide
les phrases sont bien connectées les
unes aux autres
je passe au paragraphe suivant première
phrase
deuxièmement les responsabilités ne
peuvent pas uniquement peser sur les
décideurs publics
alors c'est très clair sur la forme
la phrase est courte 12 mo et l'adverbe
deuxièmement rend la structure de la ciu
partie transparente
autre qualité l'expression de l'idée est
plutôt modéré
les responsabilités ne peuvent pas
uniquement peser sur le fond je trouve
que l'idée de l'argument n'est pas assez
précise là il faut dire ce que doivent
faire les citoyens pour renouveler la
démocratie pour rester synthétique on
peut dire qu'ils doivent participer
davantage à la vie politique
la deuxième phrase développe l'argument
en disant que la démocratie est
précisément fait pour cela pour que les
citoyens participent ce qui soit dit en
passant s'oppose à l'idée de la
nécessité d'un renouvellement
les phrases 3 à 5 montre qu'il y a des
éléments qui vont dans le bon sens
la 6ème phrase évoque la piste de rendre
le vote obligatoire
puis arthur fait du name dropping
thucydide a dit qu'un citoyen apathique
est inutile enfin il termine le
paragraphe sur une note positive
en réalité les citoyens prennent de plus
en plus conscience de leur propre
responsabilité est encore un petit coup
de name dropping pour finir cette fois
ci en oubliant de souligner la référence
bon que dire de ce paragraphe
pour une fois la première phrase me
plaît sur la forme mais pas sur le fond
ensuite l'argumentation est confuse
comme dans le reste de la dissertation
je pense qu arthur pouvait simplement
commencé en disant que les citoyens
doivent s'impliquer davantage dans la
vie politique dira ensuite qu'il ya de
bons signes de cette évolution est
prolongée en disant qu'on peut aller
encore plus loin pour appuyer ce dernier
point il aurait alors mobilisés et
développer sa seconde référence
radicaliser la démocratie de dominique
rousseau dans le dernier tiers du
paragraphe concernant la forme
l'expression écrite est toujours
efficace malgré les imperfections
c'est toujours fluide grâce au
connecteur logique
attention encore une fois où guy mes
ongles
alors est ce que le grand 2 m'a fait
changer d'avis eh bien non comme je
pouvais m'y attendre j'ai retrouvé les
défauts du grand teint l'argumentation
manque de rigueur les paragraphes de
cohérence et le propos est globalement
trop confus amour
j'ajoute que dans ce grand de arthur
verse à plusieurs reprises dans le nen
joplin de l'autre côté la copie est
facile à lire et elle mêle des
connaissances de différentes natures la
philosophie politique le droit
administratif l'actualité etc
mais bon c'est ce qu'on attend d'un
élève qui a préparé sérieusement le
concours de l'unm voilà pour le grand 2
il est maintenant temps de donner une
note à la copie
[Musique]
alors je vais faire comme je fais pour
corriger les copies des élèves de ma
formation je vais vous donner par ordre
d'importance des croissants les trois
principaux défauts de la copie puis les
toits principale qualité which the ninth
c'est parti alors le plus gros défaut de
la copie c'est l'obscurité de la
problématisation j'ai dit en commentant
l'introduction on ne saisit pas
facilement quel est précisément le
problème intellectuel que va résoudre la
dissertation je vous ai déjà dit c'est
bien plus clair et bien plus simple en
termes d'exécution de poser une seule et
unique question à la fin de
l'introduction puis d'y répondre dans l'
annonce de plan deuxième plus gros
défaut de la copie le manque de rigueur
de l'argumentation je veux dire
plusieurs choses par là les idées des
arguments ne sont pas toujours les
bonnes parce qu'il arrive à arthur de
confondre les idées générales et les
idées précises parfois l'argument
n'apparaît pas au début du paragraphe
mais à l'intérieur parfois ils n'ont pas
formulé clairement enfin le déroulement
de l'argumentation dans le paragraphe
est souvent confus arthur a du mal à se
focaliser sur l'idée directrice à
l'expliquer et à l'illustrer enfin
troisième plus gros défaut de la copie
la mobilisation des connaissances
oui arthur a de bonnes connaissances
mais il ne les mobilise pas assez
efficacement dans l'introduction déjà
plusieurs passages confine à la
récitation suite arthur utilisent
parfois des connaissances dans les
introductions et les conclusions
partielles
alors que ces partis certes uniquement à
accompagner le correcteur dans le
raisonnement enfin arthur ne développe
pas assez les références il se contente
même d'allusions vers la fin du
développement globalement je trouve
qu'il a voulu trop en faire
il connaissait bien son cours il a voulu
le montrer et il l'a fait ou détriment
de l'argumentation comme je le dis
souvent aux élèves qu'ils me contactent
une seule idée et une seule référence
par paragraphe suffisent largement pour
écrire une dissertation exceptionnel
voilà pour les principaux défauts je
pense maintenant aux trois principales
qualités de cette copie la première
qualité de cette dissertation c'est
l'expression écrite j'ai trouvé des
maladresses mais globalement c'était
facile à lire je n'ai jamais eu à faire
un effort pour comprendre ce quartier où
vous voulez dire
notamment parce qu'ils utilisent
beaucoup
logique ce qui fluidifie le propos
deuxième principale qualité de cette
copie l'impression de pertinence qui
s'en dégage j'en ai déjà parlé en
conclusion du grand teint mais je le
répète parce que c'est important
art une donne bien l'impression qu'il
est focalisée sur le sujet pour produire
cette impression il soigne ses
introduction et conclusion partielle
ces transitions et il répète
inlassablement les idées et les termes
clés il répète même trop je trouve mais
bon je ne suis pas dit une seule seconde
qu'il était hors sujet après ce n'est
pas qu'une histoire d'impression parce
que la plupart des idées d'arthur touche
juste même s'il l'est présentent de
manière confuse
enfin troisième qualités principales de
la copie la conformité idéologique alors
à mes yeux dans les circonstances de ce
concours c'est bien une qualité je l' ai
déjà dit c'est une preuve de pragmatisme
arthur ne résout pas un problème de
maths il écrit un discours qui sera
corrigée par un être humain donc s'il
veut une bonne note
il ne doit pas froisser cet être humain
il doit rester dans le bon cadre de
pensée c'est comme ça ça ne veut pas
dire que nous vivons dans une matrice
que nous sommes conditionnés
c'est simplement la nature des sociétés
humaines elles tirent leur cohésion
d'une certaine dose de conformité
idéologique en définitive peu importe
car tu repenses ou pas ce qu'il écrit il
réalise un exercice pour atteindre un
objectif
donc il dit uniquement les choses que le
correcteur certainement aux
fonctionnaires en l'occurrence il dit
uniquement des choses qu'un haut
fonctionnaire français est prêt à
entendre parfois il force un peu le
trait je trouve mais il fait ce qu'il
faut pour s'attirer la complicité de son
correcteur voilà pour les qualités je
résume tout d'un côté la
problématisation est obscur
l'argumentation manque de rigueur la
mobilisation des références n'est pas
assez efficace
de l'autre côté le style lui est
efficace
le propos produit une bonne impression
de pertinence et enfin arthur dit aux
correcteurs ce qu'il est prête à
entendre
alors maintenant qu'elles notent est-ce
que je donnerais à cette copie déjà
certainement pas 14 ou 15 parce que
l'argumentation est trop confuse mais je
pense que dix ou onze ça serait trop
sévère étant donné la qualité de
l'expression écrite
donc je
cette copie 12 sur 20 comme je les ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises je suis
globalement déçu de la copie parce que
c'était un sujet facile
la démocratie c'est carrément un thème
du programme donc étant donné que les
connaissances ne devait pas être un
problème pour les candidats j'attendais
une argumentation synthétique et
rigoureuse or celle d'arthur est confuse
voilà maintenant que devez vous retenir
de mon commentaire
le premier enseignement vous pouvez en
tirer c'est que si vous voulez trop en
faire vous ferez probablement mal
n'essayez pas d'impressionner le
correcteur avec vos connaissances
n'essayez pas de bourrée votre cours
dans votre dissertation non pour bien
faire fait simples comme je l'aï dit à
arthur je ne suis pas sûr qu'il puisse
obtenir une aussi bonne note sur un
sujet plus difficile parce que sa
méthode est trop compliqué deuxième
enseignement vous pouvez tirer de mon
commentaire
la clarté du style et survalorise à
contenu comparable une dissertation
aurélie j'ai clairement gagne 3,4 points
voire plus je pense d'ailleurs que c'est
la raison principale pour laquelle
arthur décroche un 15 malgré des
imperfections son expression écrite est
clair tout au long de la copie
d'ailleurs le rapport de juin 2019 dit
qu'il recherche
je cite un style clair dénuée
d'artifices
apprenez donc à écrire clairement
travailler votre style c'est bien plus
rentable que d'apprendre des milliers de
références parker troisième enseignement
vous pouvez tienne mon commentaire c'est
important de bien distinguer les
différents niveaux de l'argumentation
vous devez être capable de classer vos
idées par niveau de généralité en
particulier les arguments sont des idées
précises qui certes à défendre des idées
plus générale celle d'une grande partie
ou d'une sous partie du développement
la dissertation ce n'est pas un contrôle
de connaissances mais un exercice dans
lequel vous devez manipuler des idées
afin de résoudre un problème
intellectuel
voilà pour les trois enseignements à
tirer de cette vidéo
l'efficacité de la simplicité la valeur
de la clarté du style et l'importance de
bien il y est rare chizé vos idées
[Musique]
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui oui
c'était long mais je pense que c'est un
moyen efficace pour progresser
rapidement en dissertation à ce propos
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez vous
inscrire à mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie le lien doit s'afficher
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
et vous pouvez aussi le trouver dans la
description ce qui a été long se sont
aussi la préparation et la production de
cette vidéo elle m'a demandé énormément
de travail
donc si vous voulez m'aider n'hésitez
pas à me donner un pouce bleu ou à
m'encourager dans les commentaires et la
meilleure aide que vous puissiez ma
portée c'est de partager cette vidéo
autour de vous diffuser le lien auprès
de vos amis des personnes que vous
connaissez et qui prépare des concours
ou tout simplement des épreuves de
dissertation bien sûr si vous avez des
questions vous pouvez me les poser dans
les commentaires et je vous répondrai
avec plaisir voilà voilà j'espère
vraiment que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
et qu'elle vous sera utile je suis
romain et je suis toujours avec mon
fidèle aristote qui devra là bas vous
étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale rappelez vous vous n'avez pas
besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
réussir une dissertation
[Musique]